some people are just meant to be in your
life you didn't choose the hero life
fairy but eobard thawne made sure you
would become what he swore to destroy be
the fastest man on earth isn't always
easy the you and your friends from STAR
Labs make it work you're constantly up
against some mighty strong metahumans
but you always come out swinging so tell
us the truth Barry how confusing is it
to deal with multiple timelines all at
once because all these crossovers has
got our heads spinning keeping up with
the arrowverse timelines can seem like
an impossible task but once you know
which order to watch the shows in and
which crossovers to expect all the
puzzle pieces fall into place we're
about to reveal the complete arrowverse
timeline so don't go anywhere
but be warned this video is loaded with
spoilers alright now that that's out of
the way let's jump right in especially
against me yes
arrow the arrow verse is a complicated
realm and its contents can give viewers
a huge headache if they don't watch the
series in the right order the best place
to start is by watching arrow makes
sense right it is called the arrow verse
after all arrow first premiered in
October of 2012 the first episode laid
down the foundation for other DC series
to come in the pilot we find out about
Oliver Queen's quests shortly after he
is rescued from a deserted island and we
also find out about the list and how
Oliver is on a journey to write his
father's wrongs the first season of
arrow was so well received that a second
season followed shortly after and here's
where things got interesting writers got
the idea to introduce Barry Island to
the plot in hopes of creating a spin-off
series and fans ate it up it was later
revealed that the flash would receive a
backdoor pilot during the second season
of arrow and in December of 2013 Grant
Gustin made his grand debut in the
episode titled the scientist I'm Barry
Allen
from these Central City Police
Department I'm with the crime scene
investigation in the second part of that
episode Barry saved Green Arrow's life
after finding out his true identity and
a great friendship was formed at this
point
Barry's gesture average dorky guy but
once he gets back home to Central City
a lightning bolt strikes his room and
everything goes dark and that's when the
flash and Green Arrow story starts to
weave itself together the flash in 2014
just two years after arrow became an
instant hit the first season of the
flash hit the small screen to clear
things up arrows entering its third
season at this time in total arrow
fashion Barry Allen narrates his pilot
episode he brings us 14 years into the
past to the night of his mother's murder
and fills us in on his journey thus far
and once we have enough information on
the future hero we finally find out what
happened to him after the lightning bolt
polarized his bedroom at the end of
arrows three ghosts episode as it turns
out nine months has passed since Barry
saved Oliver Queen and Barry spent all
of his time in a coma by the time arrow
enters its third season it is up to par
with the Flash's timeline and it remains
that way from then on the first official
arrow flash crossover happens in season
1 episode 8 of the flash the two night
crossover takes place on both series the
first episodes of flash vs. arrow aired
on the flash whereas the second episode
The Brave and the bold aired on arrow in
these crossover episodes rainbow Raider
forces the flash and arrow to fight each
other but the heroes soon team up and
take him in boomerang down this
crossover episode was such a hit the CW
quickly realized that crossovers were
the way to go so the network set their
sights on creating two brand new series
that would eventually tie into arrow and
the flash and that's when things went
from mildly confusing to severely
complicated Supergirl in the spring of
2015 the CW's sister Network CBS decided
to experiment with a superhero series of
their own and that's when Supergirl was
born I was sent to protect earth
and that's what I'm gonna do at first
the networks didn't have any intentions
of crossing Supergirl with arrow or the
flash but in the end they just couldn't
resist
since Supergirl belonged to a different
network and was filmed in Los Angeles
instead of Vancouver coordinating
crossovers were a bit of a challenge but
they made it work
Supergirl premiered just a season four
of arrow was wrapping up which was
midway through the Flash's second season
fans of Barry Allen and Kara Danvers
celebrated the crossover that occurred
in season 1 episode 18 of Supergirl and
once again both networks were astounded
at the high ratings they received as a
result in the episode titled world's
finest Barry Allen accidentally travels
to earth 38 National City while working
on the Tachyon prototype how did you do
that Supergirl but first started as a
ploy to increase his speed and with
Barry helping Cara defeat silver Banshee
and livewire once the foes are defeated
car helps Barry get home and it's as if
he never left this marked the beginning
of the flash and Supergirl is awesome
friendship it was so fun to see these
former Glee stars come face to face on
DC soil will explain which heroes come
from which earths at the end of this
video so stay tuned legends of tomorrow
if fans of the arrowverse wanted to
watch the shows in perfect order they
would have to first watch seasons 1 & 2
of arrow and then watched season 3 of
arrow and season one of the flash at the
same time afterwards they need to watch
season 4 of arrow and top things off
with watching season 2 of the flash and
season 1 of Supergirl evidently keeping
the correct order can be quite the
challenge but those who do get to see
the timeline come together perfectly
once viewers get to season 5 of arrow
season 3 of the flash and season 2 of
Supergirl they can finally celebrate
because all three shows now exist on the
same timeline and that's when legends of
tomorrow comes in season 1 of legends of
tomorrow aired in the winter of 2016 of
all the people who ever lived I chose
you eight I certainly hope that you
won't let me and the world and once the
first season concluded it would be up to
par with the other shows in the
arrowverse the pilot episodes of legends
of tomorrow crossed over with the arrow
during its fourth season and would go on
to have another three crossover episodes
with arrow
in the same season there are some major
benefits to watching the DC shows in
perfect order one of them being that by
the time legends of tomorrow rolls
around viewers already know a handful of
the characters captain cold and heatwave
both appear in the flash before becoming
main cast members in legends of tomorrow
and then there's Professor Martin Stein
and Jefferson Jackson who are also
introduced in the flash once they join
forces to become two halves of firestorm
these two characters go on to join the
cast of legends of tomorrow and then
there are two deceased arrow characters
saralyn's
and Ray Palmer who get resurrected
before becoming Prime members of the
legends so if viewers do indeed watch
the series in perfect order they'll know
these characters backstories and legends
of tomorrow will make a lot more sense
multi show crossovers
as previously mentioned Supergirl aired
on CBS whereas the other three shows
aired on the CW this made Supergirl
crossover episodes a lot more
challenging to film both networks were
sure that crossovers were off the table
but in the summer of 2016
just as legends of tomorrow and
Supergirl were wrapping up their first
seasons CBS chose to move Supergirl to
the CW so this meant all four shows
would be filmed in Vancouver making it
easier to film multi show crossover
episodes in season two of Supergirl Cara
managed to fly through her breach to
earth one where she helps the flash and
Green Arrow fight off the invading
Dominator aliens this three night
crossover aired on the flash and then
arrow and lastly own legends while it
didn't appear on Supergirl Kara Danvers
was a part of all three episodes at this
point in the timeline arrow was on its
fifth season the flash was on its third
and Supergirl and legends were on their
second crisis on Infinite Earths all
four shows would go on to have dozens of
crossover episodes all of which received
amazing reviews but it looks like the CW
is about to welcome a new show into the
mix however they have stressed that
Black Lightning doesn't belong to the
arrowverse still fans aren't convinced
since Black Lightning will be included
in the multi show crossover crisis on
Infinite Earths which is all set to
start airing on December 8th 2019 but
Black Lightning isn't the only new
series that will
joining the multi show crossover as
Batwoman will also join the party now
that we have a better grasp on the
arrowverse timeline let's take a look at
the mini Earth's our heroes are sworn to
protect the multiverse the multiverse is
home to an endless amount of parallel
universes and our heroes have traveled
between these worlds on more than one
occasion
all of these occupy the same place in
space but they vibrate at a different
frequency so they can't see one another
so let's kick off things with earth one
which is where three of the major DC
series take place arrow the flash and
legends of tomorrow all exists on earth
ones timeline then there's earth - a
parallel world that shows its many
phases in season two of the flash this
is where a zoom is from it is also home
to dr. Harrison wells the one who didn't
get killed and replaced by eobard thawne
Jesse wells also hails from Earth -
however she chooses to reside in earth 3
alongside Henry Allen's doppelganger
after earth 3 there's a significant jump
to earth 38 which is home to the
notorious Cara Danvers we also know of
earth 53 commonly referred to as Earth X
which was introduced in the 2017
crossover episode crisis on Earth X are
you still with us because there's more
now let's not forget about Earth 4 252
although they are not commonly
referenced they do exist
we know that Harrison Wolfgang wells
comes from earth 12 as shown in season
four of the flash then there's the
wizard well as the gray who comes from
earth 13 and also pops up in season four
of the flash Cisco Ramones ex-girlfriend
olivia comes from earth 16 and earth 19
is where Cisco's girlfriend [ __ ] is
from Cisco also briefly dates a handful
of girls from Earth's 35 37 47 and 48 as
you can see the multiverse is a very
complicated place it might even be more
complicated than the arrowverse itself
luckily the writers of the era verse
know what they're doing and continue to
throw new and exciting earths our way
are you excited to watch the multi show
crossover crisis on Infinite Earths tell
us in the comments and while you're at
it tell us which air / series is your
favorite and that's a wrap
thanks for watching the things don't
forget to hit that subscribe button and
be sure to give this video
a big thumbs up we'll see you next time